[Music]
welcome to la chaux-de-fonds welcome
welcome
[Music]
my name is free entry to guinea I
work at the
international watchmaking museum in la chaux-de-fonds as
a restorer on  works we
work on
watchmaking objects every day whether it
's watches clocks all
hourglass timepieces this guy there and we will
repair things that are broken
damaged or that are no longer in
working order and then after we have cleaned and
then the ascent for its operation
you must above all like the mechanics and
then the delicacy the precision the
chaux-de-fonds life on the watchmaking
including many factories which are
established here that they make live the
whole region
[Music  ]
bon and patrick couillaud i am the
managing director of girard perregaux he
came to settle in la chaux-de-fonds in
i would say that la chaux-de-fonds is one
of the towns where time is below
in the  map of the prin  cipal
watchmaking manufacture and I would say that
the lime-de-fonds in oil very
important
the times are very variable production
of the world it can be from a few months to
several years
when an extremely complex movement
the price of the worlds varies little in the case
of  gerard perrigault it's going to start
around $7000 and go
up to over a million dollars these
different elements of the world all is
made a parent individually
both design and that's
what makes this place  unique and expertise
that have an obsession with time
mastering time calculating time
hello everyone - julia ballon I
welcome you to my store I go
to watchmaking in la chaux-de-fonds very much
in the field of  watchmaking for
more than 20 years and then I have been a
watch collector for more than
20 years also
as we are in the life of
champions more precisely we sometimes have
the chance to acquire pieces that are
united  that
we always have more objects the
guy of precious time to repair here
I have a nice example of a pocket world
automata that I am going to operate this
watch will
require enormous know-how then it
also highlights all the know-how of
our  region and from our relocated cradle
I am lucky to have always been
somewhere a little conditioned sponsored
by a watchmaking atmosphere because my
grandfather has always been immersed in watchmaking
are my grandfather's father also
to its importance  capital for
fund lime
[Music]
haga